[Musique]
il n'est pas de porte sans serrure
il n'est pas de serrure sans clé
il n'y a pas de clé sans mystère j'ai
entendu parler d'une clé
la clé
énigmatique certains veulent la protéger
d'autres l'exterminés elle est la plus
convoitée de ce monde
pour la trouver elle demande
persévérance et amneségation
il me fallait trouver le point le point
d'entrée le point d'entrée de la clé
[Musique]
mes recherches mais pas ma patience est
probablement ma destinée on convergé
vers ce lieu atypique
le lieu tout commence
l'entrée de la clé
[Musique]
salut vous l'avez compris aujourd'hui on
va s'attaquer à un ouvrage incroyable ça
s'appelle la clé c'est un livre un livre
énigme mais c'est pas un livre d'énigme
un magnifique ouvrage qui est accompagné
d'une petite lampe uvée qui va permettre
aussi de voir des détails cachés à
l'intérieur du livre c'est un monde un
univers entier très fourni qui a des
complots politiques des complots
guerriers il y a des mystères à
l'intérieur vous pouvez prendre ce livre
et le lire en entier et passer
complètement à côté du côté énigme du
livre c'est pas un problème c'est un
vrai livre d'histoire mais nous on va
s'intéresser au énigmes aujourd'hui le
concept est très simple il y a une
énigme à résoudre sur chacune des
doubles pages ça fait 75 énigmes c'est
pas un niveau facile c'est pour adulte
ou pour adolescent mais il faut minimum
40 heures de jeu a priori pour pour
résoudre le livre en entier le livre est
composé de cinq chapitres qui ont une
narration différente au début de chaque
chapitre il y a un nuage de mots c'est
tous les mots qu'on doit trouver à
l'intérieur des énigmes et à la fin de
chaque chapitre qu'on a tous les mots il
faut relier ça pour avoir un symbole
lorsqu'on a résolu les cinq chapitres et
donc trouver les cinq symboles il forme
à E5 un mot ce mot c'est la clé qu'on
doit tester sur le site internet de la
clé online je vais pas vous spoil tout
le livre on va se concentrer dans le
premier chapitre on va découvrir des
énigmes grandes particularités de ce
bouquin c'est qu'il y a aucune
indication c'est vraiment un livre à
lire et il faut comprendre soi-même quel
est l'énigme comment la résoudre à
chaque double page c'est toujours un
nombre ou un symbole ou un mot et un
discord qui existe il est accessible
depuis le site officiel et les deux
auteurs famélia est à Harnes sont
régulièrement dessus alors quand on
l'ouvre on tombe sur un alphabet orné
donc une correspondance symbole lettre
ou symbole syllabes ou chiffres de 0 à 9
la lampe UV on l'a une connexion
Internet j'en ai une pas loin alors on
va attaquer directement la première page
c'est à l'aube des temps que baryon vit
le jour son regard rougeoyant se posant
tout autour des échos du nez en bruit
sans arrêt il suit publicité autant
qu'il s'éteindrait quand il s'envolait
pour ne laisser que son ombre des
particules glissées de ces ailes sombres
alors que sur sa crête on deviné les
âges le temps et les siècles épouser les
nuages je trouve que le texte là est
relativement clair j'ai l'impression
qu'on me dit des particules glissées de
ces ailes sombres donc on va regarder
partout tout autour des ailes alors que
sur sa crête on devinait les âges donc
on va peut-être regarder comme ça la
crête si on voit quelque chose voilà
très clairement il y a marqué une donc
là on a une ici j'ai pris de quoi noter
des amis bien sûr ils disent de sa crête
on deviné les âges il y a deux grandes
et quatre petites très clairement là
dans le jaune il y a marqué corne
d'accord là il y a 100 très clairement
dans le fond parce qu'à l'image ça rend
encore plus nette pour vous que pour moi
là il y a un ici il a une corne sans an
toute cette zone on a rien trouvé de
spécifique on va passer à la lumière UV
dans les nuages il y a rien dans le
texte il y a rien sur
et à rien le soleil peut-être alors
est-ce que j'ai tout trouvé c'est ça la
difficulté c'est ce que j'ai tout trouvé
quoi donc on a trouvé 4 données et de
ces données moi je dois un extrait un
symbole ou un nombre ou un mot que je
dois être capable de retrouver ensuite
ici une corne ah par exemple une corne
c'est peut-être une corne vaut 100 ans
alors que sur sa crête on deviné les
âges donc ça crée c'est ça donc on
pourrait dire c'est 100 200 300 400 500
600 c'est peut-être une corne vaut 100
ans ça tient debout quand même histoire
correspond point d'interrogation pense
que vous serez d'accord avec moi dans
les commentaires et dans ces cas-là ça
ferait une deux trois quatre cinq six
cornes égal 600
et dans le nuage
59 bon on a 600 ici en gros en gros en
plus donc ça ferait 600 en premier quoi
allez on va garder le 600 pour l'instant
et puis on va continuer d'évoluer dedans
rien n'empêche de revenir après
[Musique]
comprendre l'énigme qu'il y a très
clairement on est très attiré par tout
tous ces petits bouts là il y en a
combien un deux trois quatre cinq six 12
13 14 15 symboles qu'est-ce que j'ai en
plus de ça dans ces symboles il y a des
sortes de lettres là j'ai un T là il y a
une sorte de J ça je sais pas trop ce
que c'est si c'est un N ou un M je vais
faire comme il est représenté
[Musique]
ok qu'est-ce que je fais de tout ça moi
donc c'est ça aussi qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il faut vraiment comprendre
l'histoire si l'histoire en elle-même
est pas compris je pense qu'on peut pas
comprendre tous les indices noble père
ça peut être interpréter dans deux sens
une paire une paire d'objets de son cri
venait sa parole capitale capitale les
lettres capitales donc il y a le mot
père il y a le mot capital père et
capitales et qu'est-ce que j'ai en paix
et en capital en capital j'ai quoi j'ai
le T le js de l et le O donc j'ai un mot
de 8 lettres là ça c'est juste si je me
réfère sa parole capitale est-ce qu'on
peut faire un mot avec ça et du coup les
minuscules qui me restent alors ça c'est
toujours pas si c'est un M ou un
on a dit qu'ici on était en astolie je
peux le faire astolie avec ça attends
mon j c'est pas un J majuscule c'est un
J minuscule donc ça veut dire que là je
peux faire avec ça il y a un anagramme
je peux faire astoli donc l'univers on
se trouve et est-ce qu'on peut faire un
beau ici avec avec le reste est-ce que
c'est une paire de mots qui veulent dire
quelque chose un mot avec un J et un o
je regarde plus dans le nuage si j'en ai
un en fait c'est intéressant de regarder
le nuage parce que comme ça ce sont les
trucs que je dois trouver alors
évidemment c'est bourré de l'heure de
partout mais ça peut m'inspirer quand
même pour plus tard de connaître un peu
le sein bonsoir j'aurais rien de spécial
moi je vais par contre il y a astolique
et là comme ils disent que de son cri
venait sa parole capitale je garde que
les capitales je fais un Anagram ça me
fait assez au lit noble père de tous les
atomes créés je me suis dit c'était
peut-être une paire de choses pas
tellement l'impression quand même je
vais garder à Story pour l'instant donc
on garde 600 et on garde astoly on va
passer à la double page suivante
[Musique]
vous avez vu le travail les
illustrations elles sont votre dingue
elles sont incroyables tel un gars les
touchant la surface de l'eau aux notes
colorées ondulant sur les flots la
nature éclata en une symphonie sur le
rythme effréné d'une noble élégie
qu'est-ce qu'une élégie et bien
Jean-Michel on va le découvrir tout de
suite en tout cas là toute la thématique
est musicale comme un poème lyrique
exprimant une plainte douloureuse ou des
sentiments mélancoliques là on a une clé
de clé de face je vois une clé de faces
qui correspond quand même à l'univers
très musical est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
clés ailleurs là je vois comme un r ici
en fait il est intéressant parce que ça
me rappelle un peu des chasses au trésor
même si là ça n'a rien à voir avec une
chasse au trésor c'est à dire qu'en fait
tu commences tu évolues tu t'imprègnes
de l'univers tu cherches pas à tout
comprendre ça a pas l'air si linéaire
que je suis en train de le faire en fait
ça peut être feuilletable d'avance tu
notes des trucs mais comme pour les
chasse au trésor vaut mieux avoir un
carnet et noter tout ce qu'on voit tout
ce qu'on pense clé de Fages je l'ai vu
dans le nuage depuis tout à l'heure j'ai
vu clé de sol et j'avais vu clé de faim
sur cette page là clé de faille ici
après encore une fois ça peut être un
leurre ils savent qu'ils ont mis une clé
de foi donc ils peuvent mettre les
trains avec les de sol pour faire genre
c'était la clé qu'il fallait trouver
alors que pas du tout c'est cette fin
qui m'embête là mais personne ne Sud
donc ce qu'il pense à deux pas même une
confession à nos aïeux cette phrase j'ai
l'impression qu'elle fait refait un truc
genre la lettre à Élise quoi j'ai envie
de regarder si ben non c'est forcément
un mois on va continuer d'avancer on va
rester un petit peu sur la clé de fa
pour l'instant comme si c'était ça la
réponse
[Musique]
déjà la prière rassembla les dévots à
l'aube de ce bouleversement nouveau le
déjà la prière est écrit en gras là bon
là on a clairement tous ces symboles là
qu'on est en train de voir ici qui me
rappelle un petit peu ce qu'on voyait
là-bas d'ailleurs je vais voir si ici si
je vois une correspondance très c'est
très dur à comprendre c'est symboles
waouh j'ai pas fait gaffe tout à l'heure
quand j'ai ouvert que ça pouvait être si
difficile on peut on peut déjà commencer
par noter tout ça je fais un petit coup
quand même des lettres UV
au cas où je n'oublie pas que j'avais
mon petit mot avec les minuscules là
où il y avait un J un haut si je vois un
mot dans l'histoire qui ressemble j'en
prendrai rêve on a trois couleurs
principales on a le rose pâle on a on va
dire le vermillon et on a le vert voilà
on va dire rouge rose pâle rouge et vert
là c'est j'ai dit que ça c'était un T
majuscule
[Musique]
donc j'ai quoi j'ai Evie j'ai tenu et
j'ai dragon sachant que le dragon c'est
sur le truc des vermillants et qui
disent l'incandescence de son regard
vermillon ne fut plus qu'une lointaine
évocation dragon il doit être dans le
nuage quoi qu'il arrive donc ça va pas
m'apporter grand chose mais on va au
moins vérifier qu'il est bien dans le
nuage dragon
crois pas qu'il y soit le dragon
déjà la prière rassembla les dévots ça
c'est écrit en gras je me mettais sorti
de la tête déjà la prière ce qu'on a un
jeu de mots est-ce qu'on a un anagramme
là dedans c'est possible je vais
peut-être faire l'impasse là pour
l'instant je sais que je l'ai pas que
j'ai rien du tout je pense qu'ici il
doit y avoir un anagramme je vais mettre
un agramme point d'interrogation et je
reviendrai dessus je pense un peu plus
tard on va continuer voir si quelque
chose me débloque
[Musique]
ça sent pas le la bonne zone pour mettre
des choses là oui
ça se sentait bien alors on va déjà
regarder ailleurs il a un dessin si peu
chargé c'est bizarre il y a beaucoup
beaucoup
de choses donc en gros il y a des sortes
je sais pas du tout comment ça ressort à
la caméra il y a des sortes de points
tout seul il y a des points avec des
flèches genre lui il va là lui il va là
lui est-ce que c'est juste un jeu un jeu
de choses à relier je vais tenter de
d'assembler les trucs par rapport aux
directions que je vois parce qu'il y a
des frictions vols on peut les effacer
donc là il y a lui qui va ici là il y a
lui qui va là lui qui va là
[Musique]
ça ça pourrait faire un N ça ça pourrait
faire un e donc j'ai pas mis les flèches
pour lui est-ce que avec les flèches il
faut pas continuer que lui fait ça il
faut le continuer là ça c'est une flèche
en continu en haut et là faudrait aller
là et là comme ça mais en n e a n t mais
presque certains de l'avoir vu dans le
nuage des mots mais
là c'est sûr c'est néant
[Musique]
analysons cette double page Loïc j'aime
beaucoup votre pull bonjour
[Musique]
ouais c'est trop dark bonjour Qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire sur cette page une
énigme il y a un truc qui me saute aux
yeux en vrai
c'est ce que j'avais dit au début mais
tu l'as pas entendu en vrai ça te
rappelle quoi ça
du morse ça me fait penser à un truc
d'ordi c'est le réduire le truc passer
en plein écran
internet peut-être nous pouvons explorer
à l'aide de la lumière violette
[Musique]
c'est quoi c'est un pourcentage dans un
triangle c'est dure un peu le
pourcentage des il
je parle pas de la coiffure p1819 on a
trouvé slashow on a trouvé ce symbole on
a trouvé un plus un moins c'est pas
Firefox
la queue du renard du coup et on a eu
aussi ce truc là avec un petit chemin
j'ai beaucoup de mal à m'interpréter je
vais aller sur le site de la clé online
et je vais ajouter slashow déjà pour
voir la clé online ah bah je suis tombé
là dessus c'est juste des rangs 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 sites ok
notre but étant toujours de trouver un
mot ou un nombre ou un symbole d'une
manière certaine par contre tu peux
trouver des choses qui après te
redéblock faut pas hésiter à avancer
dans le truc donc on va avancer
[Musique]
les symboles ça c'est un i je crois
franchement si c'est ça je suis chaud
[Musique]
mon petit pote n'a pas 20 21 on a trouvé
deux séries de signes alors on va
essayer de se les faire dans l'ordre
tu n'as pas de tu n'as pas de directive
d'énigme
l'existence même de Céline denim à
chaque fois que tu trouves un mot un
symbole ou un truc tu l'entoures ici et
ensuite tu les reliras ensemble dans
l'ordre de tous les êtres ça fera un
symbole ça fait Sophie la girafe c'est
possible ce serait assez stylé comme il
y a cinq chapitres tu auras cinq
symboles tu gagnes un Bitcoin tu gagnes
rien tu gagnes beaucoup
d'animation après toute une cinématique
à débloquer bravo vous avez gagné parce
que ça ressemble un peu à templier non
qui parle parce que lui on nous l'a
présenté ici ok
de lui non c'est des petites perles de
pays
c'est dans quoi les personnes dans les
moules non
on est en train de vivre un truc qui
était largement conseillé par le jeu qui
est de faire ça à plusieurs dès le début
c'est déjà tu me parles mieux les gens
viennent dire effectivement loïc est
agressif ça je lis le commentaire
effectivement loïc est agressif et du
coup Fabien je t'ai rejoint sur
Instagram pour un peu plus de
bienveillance merci beaucoup merci ton
déjà rejoint sur Instagram celle qui se
désabonnent et se réabonnent non ça veut
dire que en même temps il s'abonne à
cette chaîne Youtube Peter et demi on va
peut-être s'arrêter là on va peut-être
s'arrêter là après on peut faire les
50-60 heures de jeu si tu veux
sur mon Instagram
vous avez vu on a vite fait de passer
quelques heures dessus on n'est pas très
loin pourtant on est encore dans la
découverte de l'histoire comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure je pense qu'il
vaut mieux commencer par lire l'histoire
entièrement se plonger dans cet univers
qui a l'air très dense très riche pour
ensuite faire les énigmes en connaissant
un petit peu mieux ça et donc un peu
comme une chasse au trésor même si c'est
un pas une j'insiste dessus l'idée c'est
quand même d'avancer de toucher un petit
peu à tout je pense au départ pour pour
comprendre déjà un petit peu les
mécaniques du jeu et surtout de pas se
bloquer à essayer de tout faire en
linéaire de se dire il faut absolument
que je finisse telle page avant d'aller
à la prochaine et d'avoir son carnet de
notes c'est important c'est le carnet de
notes bref je trouve ce projet là
vraiment incroyable dans sa densité dans
l'histoire dans la créativité dans les
énigmes merci encore à fannelia et à
Tarn de m'avoir offert cet exemplaire je
vous mets tous les liens dans la
description c'était un petit peu
différent d'un casse-tête aujourd'hui
mais on sait casser la tête n'est-ce pas
Loïc mais ça m'a vite cassé je vais
rentrer chez moi d'ailleurs
allez ça marche pas si tu peux pas faire
un arrêt de travail pour casse-tête non
je vais vérifier ça doit aller à la page
32 merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo pensez à vous abonner à cette
chaîne Youtube si c'est pas encore le
cas ça soutient ça fait plaisir à mon
compte Instagram j'en ai parlé je crois
j'en ai parlé dans la vidéo je crois je
crois une fois j'ai dû en parler
n'hésitez pas à me rejoindre sur insta
je suis en spectacle actuellement à
Paris au Palais des Glaces tous les
mardis mercredis soir avec mon nouveau
spectacle de mentalisme du Moore passer
on se voit à la fin toujours avec
plaisir et puis si vous n'avez pas
l'occasion de venir à Paris je suis en
tournée jusqu'à juin 2023 toujours avec
ce spectacle là vous avez toutes les
dates qui s'affichent n'hésitez pas
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt c'est
à toi Loïc
[Musique]